quand je grandissais, nous étions hors
carte postale, c'était si beau,
il y avait des loups partout
et tout ce que je pouvais encore voir cette
terre et tout était si calme et je
me sentais en sécurité, nous faisions des allers-retours
vraiment parce que mes frères et sœurs plus âgés
assistaient  l'école et ils venaient dans
la communauté pour les vacances scolaires,
nous devions retourner chez Julie, nous avons été
inclus pour une frontière presque un an,
puis nous sommes retournés au garde de l'avant-poste,
peut-être une autre année à ce moment-là, ma
vie avait été perturbée alors  Je ne me sentais en
sécurité nulle part.
Je m'appelle Lavinia curly, mon nom de jeune fille
est un stylo. J'ai grandi dans un grec, j'ai
déménagé d'un endroit à l'autre à 17
ans et je me suis installé ici dans une camionnette
lorsque nous étions avant-poste. CalPERS ma mère
et mon  mon père n'a jamais cherché à se battre mes
parents étaient je suis vraiment bon pour
me garder un moi me racontant des histoires et
me disant comment être une bonne personne ma mère était
n'importe quel Anacapa anantha pour aligner ma mère
était très en proie elle était p  rayonnant
toute la journée mon père était George copiona
George acapella et il était une religion pour l'
homme il m'a donné la sagesse et il m'a
appris à aimer l'été nous serons
dans une tente puis une fois que la balle commencera à venir
mon père renflouera la maison de glace
était juste là-dedans car c'était comme du
verre partout et nous emménagerions dans
cet endroit pendant au moins un mois pendant que mon
père nous renflouait la maison, puis une
fois que la maison était faite, nous
déménagions dans la maison latérale et y vivions
pour le  hiver bien que j'aie deux
frères aînés mais ils étaient mariés avec
leur propre famille et j'étais le plus jeune
donc j'ai dû aider mon père car il n'avait
pas de fils pour l'aider et que vous
souvenez-vous le plus de ces voyages de chasse
avec votre  père marchant marchant marchant
écluse et câble
nous marchions des kilomètres et des kilomètres tous les jours
et nous rapportions cette viande de caribou
à la tasse pendant des kilomètres et des kilomètres de
montagne après le marché Je l'ai accompagné
tout au long de l'année, donc je
connaissais tout  l'âme j'ai apprécié
quand il est allé du camp de l'avant-poste à un
léchage de colle il a dit qu'il y avait un moment
où vous étiez dérangé bien ce qui
s'est passé l'agression sais quand je
grandissais il y avait cinq hommes qui
m'agressaient tout le temps je me sentais  en sécurité à la
maison et je me sentais en sécurité chez ma
sœur et ce sont les seuls endroits où je
me sentais en sécurité Je pense que la première fois que
cela s'est produit, c'était quand j'avais quatre
ans, cela a continué au fil des ans pendant dix
ans. J'étais en colère au premier mal et
confus, je savais que quelque chose n'allait pas avec
moi parce que je devenais sauvage euh je
buvais et prenais de la drogue et j'avais des relations sexuelles
avec qui que ce soit à cause de la douleur je suis
tombée enceinte à un jeune âge j'ai accouché à propos de
ma MA mes parents l'ont adopté et
à 17 j'ai adoré  un bon look pour de bon je
n'avais aucune idée d'où j'allais j'avais
juste besoin de partir j'ai toujours vu ces
hommes tous les jours tous les jours et ça me
rendait fou avez-vous déjà voulu dire à vos
parents ce qui se passait moi quand c'est
arrivé le  première fois que j'ai dit à mon  mère,
mais elle m'a battu à mort et
m'a dit de ne jamais dire ces choses, donc je n'en ai
plus jamais parlé.
J'aime
jusqu'à le blesser beaucoup parce qu'il
m'aimait et si je lui avais dit qu'il aurait
été blessé,
j'ai beaucoup reniflé quand j'étais enfant
parce que cela me rendait maintenant engourdi et
ne me rappelait pas que j'avais commencé à consommer de la
marijuana parce que c'est  Je me suis installé et puis j'ai
commencé à boire Je m'en fichais s'il
n'y avait pas d'alcool Je pense que je serais
devenu fou
Je ne savais pas
ce qui n'allait pas avec moi, je pensais que
j'étais si diabolique que j'ai essayé d'aller à ce que vous
appelez ces programmes de traitement de l'alcoolisme et de la toxicomanie
, mais je ne parlais pas de l'
abus sexuel, donc ça n'a pas
marché  jour où j'étais ivre et puis je
me suis coupé les poignets un  Et je ne me souviens même pas de
mon âge, puis quelques
années plus tard, j'ai refait ça et puis
la troisième fois que j'ai essayé de
me suicider, j'ai pris beaucoup de serviettes et
j'ai failli mourir cette fois-là, je ne me souviens de
rien sauf que j'y suis allé  dans cet
endroit très sombre, j'ai commencé à prier et une
voix m'a dit que j'avais encore un
scintillement de lumière en moi, donc
soyez là pour cela, je sortirai à travers
ce scintillement de lumière vous et j'étais hors
de cet endroit et j'étais  dans un hôpital, j'ai
essayé de me suicider peut-être trois
fois mais je n'ai jamais réussi bon je suis dieu
je n'ai jamais réussi qu'avant il a
aussi été agressé et violé quand il était enfant aussi
je ne vivais pas dans un clerc et il
vivait dans la gloire avec mon  parents donc je
ne savais pas que cela lui arrivait, il
m'a dit quand il est devenu adulte et j'ai
essayé de l'aider mais il a vu qu'il était un
homme et qu'il était différent de moi alors il a
fini par se suicider quel âge avait
un  23 dis nous beaucoup de ton fils quel
était son nom Patrick abella il était
extraverti drôle amical et parfois
très difficile à gérer il
aidait tout le monde comme quand il
grandissait il apportait toujours comme s'il y
avait de la viande de caribou et ou notre professeur
il l'attrapait juste et l'apportait
aux aînés c'est comme ça qu'il était il avait demandé
pour moi de cuisiner pour ça et donc je
cuisinais et quand ce fut fait j'ai dit à ma
fille d'aller chercher son frère et
elle est revenue et elle m'a dit qu'il
n'ouvrirait pas la porte que nous essayions de
monter par la fenêtre et  mon frère
jardin et j'ai parlé j'ai claqué la porte
et lui ai dit d'ouvrir la porte et c'est
en quelques minutes qu'il est sorti et
m'a dit d'aller vers lui alors je suis allé voir Patrick mais
il était déjà mort j'ai essayé de faire la RCR j'ai
essayé  pour le faire revivre
mais je ne pouvais pas perdre un être cher
par suicide aussi fort Je suis content de
ne pas avoir laissé mes parents ressentir cette douleur que je
pouvais Je me sentais vraiment mal à cause de ça car j'ai
essayé de me suicider plusieurs fois
et je  Je suis content de ne pas avoir réussi parce que je
n'ai pas mis mon père du côté  Je ne veux
pas pleurer,
j'ai suivi des cours de travail social et lorsque nous avons
suivi ces cours, j'ai commencé à avoir des
flashbacks, c'est maintenant la façon dont une personne
bouge et ou quoi que ce soit, tout se
déclenchait et cela me portait alors je suis
allé voir mon professeur Debbie et Marya
ces deux  les dames m'ont tellement aidé qu'elles ont en
fait pris des dispositions pour que je
descende à toronto pour une thérapie c'était
une si grande grande communauté je veux dire la ville c'était
comme une histoire sans fin et je suis allé dans la
rue yonge et c'était comme dans un
film mon  l'esprit était juste au sein de la
communauté comme dans un nouveau roman et
ce qu'il y a à univille mais quand je suis allé à
toronto c'était comme un tout nouveau monde
les thérapeutes étaient tous des blancs d'arjuna
et parce qu'ils étaient si bons
ils m'aident à m'aider à me souvenir que je
pleurais  pendant trois jours entiers, je n'ai pas pu
m'arrêter de pleurer, j'ai pensé que je n'arrêterais jamais de
pleurer, c'était comme si quelqu'un était mort,
mais ce sentiment que j'avais perdu
quelqu'un et le quatrième jour, j'ai commencé à
parler et je parle depuis
t  C'est quand je ne voulais plus vraiment
boire parce que j'ai commencé à
me soucier de moi et quand je grandissais, je
pensais que mon enfance n'était que de mauvaises
choses parce que je ne me souvenais plus de bonnes
choses et quand j'ai commencé à t'entendre, j'ai
commencé à me souvenir  de bons moments avec ma
mère aussi et le contact affectueux qu'elle
m'a donné dont je
ne me souvenais plus depuis longtemps et je
me suis amusé en fait enfant à soit je ne me suis
jamais amusé et jusqu'à aujourd'hui je
me souviens encore de mon enfant
je pense que ces  les hommes modestes souffrent
aussi, je reviens toujours à ces gars qui
m'ont agressé quand j'étais enfant à l'école
de Chesterfield et ces étudiants ont
également été agressés par leurs personnes qui
étaient censées s'occuper d'eux,
ils souffraient et ils l'ont fait pour  moi
parce que cela leur était fait, j'ai
commencé à essayer de guérir, je suis allé après qu'il ait
vraiment confronté ces hommes comme si je
devais commencer avec quelqu'un de très proche
de moi parce que c'était le plus douloureux et
que la première fois que cette personne l'a nié en
disant  que tout était dans ma tête et j'ai
dit tu sais ce n'est pas que je
voulais juste rendre ce qu'il m'a donné
parce que pourquoi il m'a donné ne
m'appartient pas je lui ai dit que ah je veux juste ses
excuses parce que c'est tout  J'ai toujours voulu
juste des excuses Je ne veux rien d'
autre Je voulais juste que quelqu'un dise que je suis
désolé qu'il l'ait fait peut-être quatre ans plus tard je l'ai
accepté dans ma tête mais je ne l'ai pas
accepté dans mon cœur et ça vient de
durer  année je l'ai finalement accepté
dans mon cœur
je vais me cacher depuis tant d'
années ça va être un
processus de toute une vie je parie que je vis juste au jour le jour
aujourd'hui ma vie est plutôt bonne je n'ai pas
à m'inquiéter  tout sauf mes
enfants je veux qu'ils aient une
vie meilleure je veux qu'ils aient une vie plus facile
sans lutter tout le temps je t'aime
tu ne peux pas le faire seul dis à quelqu'un
quelqu'un nous sommes nombreux à avoir
été abusés beaucoup d'entre nous  sont prêts à
aider une fois que vous dites que vous avez été
abusé que tout devient plus facile
et avant  or il commence à contrôler vous obtenez de l'
aide
puma je suis tellement au-dessus de mon soo geun na EK vous
ou na kena